if you are migrating to Google cloud you
are probably wondering how your team's
responsibilities might change how do you
ensure that users remain in continuous
compliance and how do you manage and
analyze cost well keep watching as we
answer some of these questions
[Music]
welcome to cloud migration 101 where we
share migration tips and tricks' in the
last two episodes we learned about
resource hierarchies access control
permissions using I am security
networking and monitoring within Google
cloud today let's address some of the
questions that impact your broader
business objectives for this let's get
Travis back hi I'm Travis today we are
going to focus on three main questions
that business stakeholders worry about
during a migration as you migrate to
cloud how will your IT responsibilities
and business processes change how can
you support and meet your regulatory
compliance requirements and how will you
assess and analyze costs and billing
let's get started with the most common
scenario you have owned and operated
your data center for years how will your
ownership access and responsibilities
change as you migrate to Google Cloud
during and after your migration the
shared responsibilities between you and
Google cloud may be different than those
who are used to the processes to
provision configure and consume
resources might also differ we have
added a link in the description for the
Terms of Service and the Google security
model that will provide you an overview
of the contractual relationship between
your organization and Google you're
probably wondering how can you support
or meet your regulatory compliance needs
for example HIPAA or gdpr during and
after your migration to Google Cloud we
provide a robust compliance Resource
Center that can provide information
about industry region and sector
specific regulations like PCI gdpr HIPAA
FedRAMP and many more if geography and
data residency are critical factors for
you Google Offers resource location
constraints to ensure workload
compliance with data residency
requirements and direct regionality
controls for many of our services now as
you move to Google cloud how can you
make sure that your users support and
meet your compliance needs
developing a governance strategy is
important to create alignment among
stakeholders in business leadership when
planning your migration you want to
establish standards around things like
naming conventions labeling strategies
access and security controls and cost
controls speaking of cost cloud billing
helps you control assess and analyze
cost it allows you to attribute spending
on a particular project or workload to
the correct cost center you can also set
up alerts for your spending budget for
example you could use cloud functions to
enforce and monitor a compliance as code
solution to verify names and labels on
provisioned resources and inspect your
own iam policies and resource hierarchy
to ensure the standards are being
followed with this solution you gain
full auditing capabilities as a
byproduct of every service and action
the last question I would like you to
answer for yourself and your
organization is what type of support and
help you need in order to take on the
migration the answer could be you will
do it all yourself with the help of
training and certifications or you would
do it partially with a partner or
completely hand it off to a partner you
have options depending on where you are
in your cloud journey talk to your
Google team for best guidance all right
I got this all right back to you that
was amazing
we learned about governance billing and
some important enterprise considerations
like shared responsibility models and
data residency for more details check
out the entire guide linked below and
stay tuned for the next episode where we
will take this migration journey forward
in the meantime give us a like subscribe
and comment below to let us know what
else you would like to learn about cloud
migration
[Music]